you can't even pronounce most the  chemicals in sunscreen he is correct  that skin cancer rates have been rising  but it's not because the chemicals in  sunscreen are causing skin cancer there  is zero evidence for that all the  evidence shows sunscreen reduces skin  cancer it's because we're living longer  so cells have more opportunity to mutate  we have different lifestyle habits  people are going on beach holidays a lot  more and doctors have gotten a lot  better at picking up skin cancer early  also if you can't pronounce something  that's not a sign to be scared of and  i'm sure quinoa and acai are probably  healthy for you it's a sign that maybe  you might want to take some chemistry  classes because then you'll find out  that this is what's naturally in a  pineapple you have two five dimethyl4  hydroxy three true h firing which  honestly makes oxybenzone a piece of  cake